nba now requires
to play the national anthem after the
dallas mavericks halt
ritual specifically mark cuban decided
to stop
playing the national anthem in the game
this is something that the nba has been
doing for a long time the league
announcement comes after the news
that dallas maf sees playing the
national anthem prior to home games this
season at the direction of owner mark
cuban the mavs have not played
the national anthem before any home
games this season a spokesperson
told nbc the announcement from bass
seems to contradict a previous statement
from india spokesperson tim frank who
told the nbc news that
teams are permitted to run their pregame
operations as they see
fit through league policy mba requires
to stand for national anthem according
to the nbc sports nbc commissioner adam
silver hasn't strictly enforced the rule
allowing players to kneel during the
anthem in the nba bubble last season so
uh you know mark cuban decides to not
play the national anthem
i don't know if well we watched the
interview together yesterday with uh
the girl from espn i don't know her name
but she's always on
rachel nichols rachel nichols and he
said look it's not that i wasn't
planning on doing it we just didn't know
if we were going to do it or not we were
just kind of listening to the audience
and some of them thought it wasn't a uh
something that represented their
community they didn't want it to be
played others wanted to be played
so we just kind of saw over and now
we're going to go back and playing it so
what are your thoughts about the
national
anthem and mark cuban i mean let me just
start off with mark cuban i know you're
listening
play the damn national anthem
i'll say it again play the damn national
anthem we're here in america
the flip side to that is you want to
kneel
you want to do the colin kaepernick
thing cool
but play the got national language tell
me why tell me we're here in freaking
america
what are we talking about what do you
mean by that so what do you mean by that
we're in america what's the big deal i
mean
like listen obviously this is the
argument that they're making so i'm
trying to see what you're arguing i mean
obviously i'm i
you know there's certain things i'm a
little left on certain things i'm a
little right on right
but where are we in the conversation
where no more
national anthem no more america the
star-spangled banner
is a divisive topic okay cool if you
wanna if you wanna
protest and kneel during the anthem i'm
good with that
i'm good with the colin kaepernick thing
raise your voice
you know social justice i'm cool with
that but to the point of saying
no national anthem are you freaking
kidding me
do you know when like when did the
national anthem like really started
sports games you did some research
uh world war one world war one right
okay so world war ii i'm assuming
it was big for me being a kid i remember
i pledge allegiance at school ever you
know
1991 the national anthem who sang it at
the super bowl remember that
whitney houston completely crushed
the national anthem we were in the
middle of desert storm
right we were at a war george w bush
senior i'm george bush senior
h.w bush she completely crushed
the national anthem from that day
forward i'm like damn
like i i get down with the national
anthem now if you
again if you want to protest you have
the right to protest
peaceful protest you totally have that
right you want to put your fist up
you want to kneel i'm good with that but
in under no circumstance in america
today
should it be even a conversation of
should we play the national anthem is
the national anthem the right thing to
do
if you don't want to be in america get
the adam out of america paul what do you
think
yeah i actually 100 percent agree with
adam here i was thinking the same thing
you at the end of the day you do have
the freedom to leave like it's just like
at a job if you don't like certain
things it's one thing to complain about
it
but at the end of the day you still
decide to be at that job
and you accept all the conditions that
occur with it if you don't like it go
find
another place you have that freedom but
you can't you can't have your cake and
eat it too
and like adam said the national anthem
is at the end that's kind of a that's
the
you're being in america you're accepting
that even immigrants that come here
you're accepting the national anthem
that's part of the deal
any any different opinion than what
we've heard so far any different opinion
thoughts mario
any different opinion than what he just
said so far i mean i just
give two cents here uh i think it's
interesting because
none no countries are perfect i mean
obviously there's there's um
baggage that comes with everything and
to to change
things completely like changing the
national anthem and traditions
i know we talked about traditions
yesterday of how changing
like people adjust to traditions
traditions traditionally
don't change based on who's there and
you've talked about this culture and
companies as well
of there's a set culture and then
people don't change it either they adapt
to it or like you guys
have mentioned they can leave you know
here's
here's what i would say with this so
what you what you said everybody what
you're saying here is
uh nine years ago i'm at
uh malibu at this one private meeting
that was taking place and prager was
there
and dennis prager said what makes
religions
work okay and he's going through it what
makes people
go to so why does catholicism work and
you know do so
why is the judaism religion
you know he's going through everything
he says because of what the word
rituals right rituals there's certain
rituals
rituals you know i'm a christian but i
would go i
prefer to pray in catholic church i
think i told you guys yes i like to pray
in catholic church even i'm a christian
some people say you're out of your mind
why do you want to do that
that's me i prefer to pray at a catholic
church because to me
i feel a little bit more uh it's
different to me when i go there when you
go to a catholic church you know
there's so many rituals christians don't
have that many rituals if you think
about it
non-denominational evangelical not that
many rituals judaism lots of rituals
christians have rituals don't get me
wrong but not at the level of
so then you bring your back and you say
okay america
mario when we came here mario was
staying with us for the first uh uh
couple days more like 20 but you know he
stayed with us here for the first couple
weeks and he's got a nice place now
right here beautiful place he's standing
right next to
him he loves his new bed by the way yeah
i bet he does so
so for for about a week mario what song
did you hear me listen to
for hours amazing grace how many times
did you hear me listen to it
honestly on repeat a couple hours every
night every night couple hours no joke
that was your go-to song everyone and
and what happened every time i listened
to it
you get emotional you have no idea how
emotional i get
that uh no no but there's a specific
song there's a specific person
anyways there's a playlist i listen to
it right and
you know it it kind of gets me to
think about how lucky i am incredible
life i have all the screw-ups in life
all the dumb stuff i've done and i'm
still forgiven i still have the life
that i have and you've still been giving
me the life that i'm living today you
become the luckiest man alive
right so national anthem what's the
national anthem
you know the greatest country in the
world fought for this people that came
before us they did what they did
and we have the ability to sit here and
we're going to forget about that
and you don't want to play just because
you don't want to play because people
are offended okay
so he said the reason why we didn't want
to do it is because certain people in
our community
didn't want to hear the national anthem
certainly let me get this straight in
dallas texas
who did that poll who did that market
research
you know how sometimes my employees
would come to me and you know sales
people come to me say
a lot of people are not happy with this
really name me one
they said really give me how many people
they are
and then it's always john and bob okay
so it's two people so don't say they
right it's two people how many agents do
we have eighteen thousand
two people say it we can't sit there for
two people you know so
so you you're living in dallas most
people in dallas or what love america
conservative hardworking entrepreneurs
business owners your ticket prices are
not five bucks if you
are listening to a community that you
said they don't want the national anthem
to be played
what is the average income of that
community let's do the numbers
why don't you make your ticket prices
available to that community why don't
you make your ticket prices 10 bucks
why do you have ticket prices so
expensive if it's so much about the
community
stop selling 100 tickets 200 tickets 500
if you're so concerned about the
community
but if somebody's buying a 500 ticket to
come watch your game
200 ticket to watch your game for two
i'm taking my kid and i do that once a
year and you know twice a year
i'm making fifty thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars you're two
hundred thousand dollars a year two by
two hundred dollar ticket if not by the
way i've never been to a basketball game
in my life i went to a basketball game
as a kid one time
and the star of that game was siddele
treat and tony smith you probably don't
even
remember those names yeah number three
early night earlier mid 90s but the
point is
nick van impe the point is nick van axel
was a star that came a little bit after
that but but here's the point i'm trying
to make to you
if you say your community doesn't want
the national anthem to be played
show us the report what percentage of
your community doesn't want to play
because let's just say that number is 10
percent yeah
say that number is 20 percent i can find
50 other things that 10 or 20 of people
are offended by you do what are you
going to do change again yeah exactly
so every single time a small minority
community comes out and says
we're gonna have change every single
time i'm part of the minority i'm middle
eastern how many middle easterners are
in america
i'm a syrian i'm part of the minority
community i don't have a four-year
degree i don't have a two-year degree
i am a minority i came to the states
green card got my citizenship a day
after i was in the military
what are you gonna do everything i
complain about you're gonna say oh my
gosh patrick's upset
no you have to work my way up have a
voice
get my okay so i don't know look
there's there's two different types of
people you know people compare him and
trump together on you know mark cuban
and trump and all this other stuff by
the way yesterday you asked me a
question said if cuban ever ran would
you vote from what i tell you
so he runs against and i gave you the
roster who did i what did i say when you
said what if you ran against bernie you
said
cuban if you ran against biden you'd say
cuban cuban all day if you ran against
trump you said i don't know what you
said no you didn't ask trump you said
you
you said you said pence oh ted cruz is
where you kind of were
i said i would be a little bit uh in the
middle because cuban at least
understands business but the difference
is the following what concerns me
he's obviously another future candidate
that wants to be a business it's a
movement right now entrepreneurs
becoming president you respect cuban
oh but there's things you don't how do
you not agree with how do you not
respect the guy
okay first how do you not respect the
guy you go to indiana university the
guy's a ridiculous numbers guy
an incredible sales guy learns to use
his numbers and sales together becomes a
billionaire
buys the maps brings the first champion
like there
is no i don't respect the guy i disagree
with this assessment of this situation
that's all it is
it's not there's no i don't respect the
guy for what he's done in his life he's
created a lot of jobs
he's brought a lot of you know different
things that he's done but i don't know
i just think uh we have to
this will cancel culture if it changes
the rituals and what america stands for
we're gonna lose our values and
principles then america is no longer
america
no because america is just a land what
is america founded on
if it is let's just kind of keep
reminding ourselves that this is what
america's on sometimes we need and
you know what affirmation is affirmation
is what hearing the same thing what over
and over and over again i had an
affirmation list with 30
affirmations people would come to my
house friends of mine would come to my
house they'd be sitting in this place or
they take the affirmation they go to the
bathroom to say pat you got all these
laminated stuff on the wall they would
read it they're like man i'm fired up
because i had these affirmations and i
can tell you some of the affirmations
till today
we have to listen to national anthem
it's an affirmation
it's an affirmation who we are it's
who we are and we listen to it over and
over and over and over my favorite
service of the year is christmas
you go to christmas you hear this story
at the end that they would put up the
candles he had one at the front all of
us would walk up
we would light up our small candle then
we'd go in our community then we'd light
up whoever's around us five ten fifteen
people and all of a sudden you got
five thousand people with candle they
would turn off the lights he would just
hold it like this
don't let the candle drop on the floor
et cetera et cetera and you would look
at it like
this is awesome you know every year you
would go to like so freaking
ritual it's a ritual it's a reminder one
person can light up a country and
inspire them
so i don't know if this is a good thing
he's doing himself i'm glad that the nba
took their position by the way
phenomenal job shut up
position so it seems to to just use the
cuban trump analogy and this is one of
the things that always frustrated me of
trump
and this is what cuban's doing right now
it's the
people are saying they people they're
saying
people are saying and and and i got to
give credit
i don't remember the interview that uh
jonathan swann the i think he's british
i'm not british new zealand or
australian reporter
they see sat down and did the one-on-one
he says who sang
tell me who's saying yeah tell me who's
saying what people are saying
it's so like i love what you said and it
was with who's that well bob and john
okay so two people
are saying so that's what people are
saying yeah
but by the way who did the research we
all do it when do we use that
when we're cornered yeah yeah well i
heard yeah but but we all heard
we all do that but when we do it when we
do
that we can still be held accountable
yeah also if you have an argument guess
what then you say
here's who said it okay fair i didn't
know then let's talk about it right
but if you say day people in our
community are not happy what percentage
of your people in your community
who is upset about the national anthem
according to such a easy way to bs your
way out of it i'm not a fan
people are saying well also the way in
the interview how we put it of
oh we did we didn't decide we're kind of
just seeing how it goes
but now we'll go back to this very safe
answer of like
of not trying to play why you could be a
president but
diplomatic i think i can also yesterday
on the interview with
adam and robert a robert was mentioning
that a lot of people don't
have financial education at the same
time i think
a lot of people don't know the meaning
of the united states flag
of the other or what we have done i mean
i come from colombia originally
so for me being here every time even
that i'm not
a uh an american u.s citizen born
here i always stand up and give my
respect to the flag
just because all the great things that i
have gotten for
coming to america so i just think that a
lot of u.s citizens
in high school i went to high school
here in united states college
they don't teach us the value of what
united states of america of america
means
yeah and this is a guy that gave yeah
you know he
fought to come here from what did you
come here from uh 14 years old
14 years old you got your bachelor's
degree yes on your own dime
who paid for it i was working 46 hours a
week
while going to school how old were you
when you got the bachelors in those two
hey i finished at 21. and how many how
much family you had here while you were
in i have no family here no family i
mean that's that's the story
that's chris hunter but that's the
question steven
francis scott key who wrote the anthem
was a slave owner and most people didn't
know that last that to last five years
so what's
so that's what drives people crazy and
want to change
the america the beautiful soyboy mafia
hashtag so your community
yeah let me give the answer to that my
perspective just so you know
assyrians were slave owners blacks were
slave owners
jews were slave owners you go back 200
years ago 300 years ago
every culture on slaves
every culture on slaves there is not one
that never owned slaves
africa owned slaves they do many small
till today there are many countries that
own slaves what are we gonna do
so now we have to get rid of all the
history of everybody that at one point
had it is that what we're gonna be doing
so so what if right now somebody said
this one large insurance company that's
one of our competitors
and they've been around since 1868. okay
it's based out of new york hence
you okay so did you know
that back in the days they sold life
insurance to
slave owners so one of my guys said
we should use that when we're going up
against our competitors and bring that
up i said you're never going to do that
why because if they did it other people
did it
that was legal back then it was stupid
it was not good it wasn't anything that
we agree with today
but back then it was what legal
okay very simple legal and if it was
illegal back then no one is breaking
what
the law okay very simple so does it mean
we endorse it of course not
does it mean we support it absolutely
not does it mean we sit there and we say
oh my gosh you know it's it's so who
cares no
that's not what we're saying it wasn't a
law back then
so large insurance companies uh uh what
do you call it they
sold insurance to slave owners should we
shut all of them down
all the banks here all the banks in
america every single one of them bank of
america bank of italy used to be bank of
italy
so every single one of the banks in
america finance
and help open up accounts for slave
owners should we shut down all the banks
should we shut down all the bank that's
what we should do so every book you ever
read that's an
old book okay we're talking about 200
years ago that are classics
oh somebody in their family should we
get rid of that book so is this the
direction we're gonna go
so so a crime everybody committed now we
should bring you back and because of
that embarrassed in public is that the
direction we're going
again that is a form of a nuclear war
because if you constantly go and say but
you did this
79 years ago but you did this 200 years
ago look at what happened kevin hart
who didn't want to see kevin hart do the
oscars who didn't want to see him as the
host
everybody wanted to see him do be the
host but no
back in 2014 here's what kevyn r tweeted
are you kidding me
and then they went through what they did
with kevin hart now so i
to me it is part of the tradition it's
what we've used
everybody and anybody that we know on
their resume there is something bad
including yourself kenyon i bet you if i
were to go and do hire somebody fifty
thousand dollars and i told them your
project is to go investigate to see what
bad things you did
i guarantee we would bring out some
things that you wouldn't be happy with i
mean we're human we're not perfect
that's the point of us are perfect we
make mistakes
that's just the way it is what's that
one song i'm only human
born to make mistakes it's one of the
best commercials but
go ahead uh and i think another thing
there is kind of you're judging the past
with today's
perspective and today's uh values and
principles that we have
or our viewpoints right now which just
doesn't make sense because
times change things that are okay in the
past aren't
okay now and vice versa things that are
okay now aren't
weren't okay then so you're just you're
confusing the times and how
you look at things and in that case
there's going to be wrong things with
everything i mean
again we're human we're not perfect we
make mistakes
and at different points in time those
things are okay or those things are
normal
watch this i can't hear my okay thank
you so
what is february black history black
history month yeah okay
america do you know what percentage
americans are african america are
african
13 exactly good number that's the number
13.4 percent
do you know what percentage of our
company are african-american
out of our 18 000 30 20 22
between 20 to 22 50 latino 50 latino 20
to 20
african-american right okay 20 white
where we at
you guys are up there okay like top five
no no not you guys
but but it's top five but here's the
point i'm trying to make to you
does this mean that we don't have
you know 50 of the company to be white
that
we're racist again like you understand
what i'm saying like what are you going
to do every time you're racist against
somebody
every company you know like but this sun
this month is black history month so the
teacher
asks my son uh which character do you
want to
write a report about for black history
month at the school that he's going to
so him and my wife are having a
conversation together and my son says
because my son has read a lot of books
on martin luther king any book i get
that i can give my martin luther king i
want you
tico i want him to read it so
he says i want to write about martin
luther king jen says why don't you try
somebody else because everybody else is
doing martin luther king
he says okay he comes back he says you
know what mom i want to do it on rosa
parks
he said this yesterday he said okay son
so he's doing his report on rosa parks
has
how does he know about rosa parks he's
read multiple books on rosa parks why
because
we want to teach him the history of
america
we don't sit there and say don't read
this
you know read this here's what happened
dude i went and seen the real
bus of rosa parks that was i went to the
bus where it was in dearborn it's in
ford museum eric and i drove as we were
driving here and he gave me a lot of
crap for this was because we were
driving through alabama
and i saw we were about to pass
montgomery and then selma was further
south so i was like let's just drive
through selma
and uh pete something bridge where they
the famous bridge where they marched
over it
we drove over it and kind of just
checked out the area so absolutely
there's there's a lot you can learn and
there's a lot you can
you have to kind of know of it to not
repeat the mistakes what's the quote
those who don't read history repeat
history yep
adam i think even just what we're doing
right now
you're giving your perspective you're
giving your perspective i'm giving my
perspective
we all have different perspectives it's
important
i'm not saying you're 100 right you're
100 wrong it's important to talk things
out one thing that stands out to me even
on the podcast i remember when we were
during the middle of all the protests
george floyd
they were going down and removing a lot
of the confederate statues ruining them
all
and you asked me a question should the
confederate statues
be removed and listen no fan of
confederacy whatsoever
like not even close um and i give a very
emotional
response and i hell yeah take them down
get the hell out of here
and people are like what do you mean
take them down i'm like get them out get
[ __ ] them
and then after cooler heads prevailed i
listened to some other perspectives
i re-thought my perspective i reanalyzed
my stance of this i said you know what
they should go in a museum for history
if you want to learn there's a
confederate museum over there we can't
cancel the past we can learn from it if
you're not if you don't learn
from history you're destined to repeat
it so i remember on another podcast i
gave a um a reform my answer and i said
well you know i thought about it
and i'd like to reverse course and i you
know i don't think they should just
remove everything but i don't think it
should be out there in the public
to be grandstanded on like these are
these people weren't heroes at the end
of the day they were traitors
but it is part of our history so put it
in a museum
you know if you want to learn about it
go for it so
what's important is to have a
conversation to hear your thoughts to
hear my thoughts
to hear the blm social justice thoughts
to hear
why you know the the south will rise
again hear their perspective talk it out
i did an interview
with daryl davis the most important
thing you can do is respect somebody's
opinion
and be willing to listen you might
disagree but hear them out and when you
can talk to somebody
and you can have an open dialogue that's
where you'll find some compromise in the
middle
the cancer culture up get out you're out
go up but that's where we are though
that's where we are it's a very
dangerous life unfortunately that's what
we ask
i told robert kiyosaki i said we are
living in the walk and walking on actual
society
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye